Donald Trump did something that actually
takes a little bit of careful planning
he was able to combine slurs against
Native Americans with anti-semitic
tropes and one of the most unusual
combinations of ignorance and
stereotyping and character assassination
that we've seen thus far in the campaign
so Trump went to a group of mostly
Jewish voters and warned them that
Pocahontas aka Elizabeth Warren is going
to take all of their dollars playing on
the trope of the rich Jew who's number
one priority of course is hoarding cash
this was Donald Trump speaking to the
Israel American Council Trump shows up
and starts talking to them like
everybody just loves Trump of course
most are very liberal and don't like
Trump although maybe this crowd was a
little bit different and at the big
picture level Donald Trump seems to
maybe recognize that because he actually
says even though some of you don't like
me you're not gonna vote for Pocahontas
cuz she'll take all your money what you
care about most is money and that's why
even if you don't like me you're going
to vote for me take a look at what
Donald Trump had to say a lot of you are
in the real estate business because I
know you very well
you're brutal killers not nice people at
all but you have to vote for me
abductors you're not gonna vote for
Pocahontas I can tell you that you're
not gonna vote for the wealth tax yeah
let's take a hundred percent of you
wealth away no no even if you don't like
me some of you don't some of you I don't
like it all actually and you're gonna be
my biggest supporters because you'll be
out of business in about 15 minutes if
they get it what Trump is saying here is
actually double playing on an
anti-semitic trope Trump is playing on
the idea of the rich Jew but he's also
playing on the idea of the rich Jew who
doesn't like Donald Trump but values
their money over making the right
political choice that's best for the
country so he suggests even if you don't
like me you would vote for me anyway so
that Pocahontas doesn't take your money
without maybe even realizing it Donald
Trump is playing off of multiple
anti-semitic tropes there and then he
adds Pocahontas to it sort of as the
cherry on top this is another version of
the dual loyalty trope I'll explain what
I mean by that often with American Jews
there is this dual loyalty trope of how
loyalty to Israel may cloud the loyalty
to the United States even for Jews who
have never been to Israel and are just
Americans and there's no reason to
suggest that whatsoever in this case
what you have is the idea of loyalty to
their own wealth clouding or superseding
loyalty to the United States wherein
Trump is saying even if you think I'm
bad you would still vote for me in order
to protect your money from Pocahontas
Elizabeth Warren at another point in
this total gongshow speech Donald Trump
actually said if Jared Kushner can't get
Middle East peace done nobody can which
is of course hilarious because we knew
from day one that Jared Kushner was
maybe one of the last people that should
be involved in negotiating middle Middle
East peace but that's maybe a topic for
a different day this has been the mo
from the start we're going to do X Y Z
it will all be super easy then X Y Z
doesn't happen who knew it could have
been so hard that even the best person
to do it Jared Kushner wasn't able to
get it done so the slurs of Pocahontas
continued I guess I should mention even
though it's pretty obvious Trump
mentioned Warren's a hundred percent
wealth tax plan as from suggests I'm
sure most of you know that that's not
true there is no 100 percent wealth tax
plan can you imagine for a moment the
outrage on Fox News if Barack Obama had
said any of these things you have to
vote for me you have no choice
anti-democratic dictator Obama hinting
at declaring Martial Law but literally
if Jared Kushner can't do it it can't be
done
can you imagine Barack Obama saying
something like if Hillary Clinton as
Secretary of State can't do it it simply
can't be done arrogant pompous Obama
thinks law school professors are the
only same thing some of you don't like
it at all but you are going to be my
biggest supporters because you'll be out
of business in 15 minutes if they get it
what 24-hour news cycle for days
if Barack Obama were to have said
something like that it's almost like
Trump is saying out loud with some
anti-semitic advisor told him I imagine
behind the scenes before Trump goes on
stage someone comes up to trump and they
say listen Donald these rich Jews are
gonna love you because they're not gonna
want to be wealth taxed by Pocahontas
okay so just bear that in mind when
you're speaking to them got it got it
most politicians then when they go out
they don't repeat that stuff verbatim
Trump of course is not most politicians
and he repeats it all verbatim and again
just a gong show
strange interview that on lots of
trumpets even the inappropriate nature
of that speech would be completely lost
on them they would again say some of it
was jokes and then most of it is just
Trump not kowtow to the politically
correct crowd and simply telling it like
it is they are beyond reach but
hopefully folks in our audience
understand what's going on here